[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis einen schönen guten abend und
herzlich willkommen den sport gleich von
norbert könig genommen in den kommenden
fast 20 minuten haben wir unter anderem
diese themen für sie
omikron auf dem vormarsch in frankreich
steigen die fallzahlen massiv und das
kabinett berät über verschärfte regeln
sorge um silvester geschäft in
österreich gilt nun eine sperrstunde für
restaurants anstoßen um mitternacht ist
dort also nicht erlaubt und
spektakuläre bilder aber auch riesige
schäden der vulkanausbruch auf
leipheimer ist nach drei monaten vorbei
der berg bleibt aber im blick
in frankreich zeigt sich bei der
ausbreitung von omikron was uns auch
bald in deutschland blühen könnte denn
in unserem nachbarland hat sich die
virusvariante bereits so schnell
verbreitet dass sie bis ende des jahres
vorherrschend sein könnte schauen wir
uns das in seoul an am 4 zwölfter
meldete frankreich erstmals mehr als
50.000 neue infektionen innerhalb von
drei wochen hat sich die zahl nun
verdoppelt auf den rekordwert von über
100.000 am ersten weihnachtsfeiertag die
inzidenz in frankreich liegt nun bei 7
125,6 und die französische regierung
sieht sich zum handeln gezwungen thomas
walther aus paris
omikron führt zum sturm auf frankreichs
testzentren vor weihnachten machte die
regierung nicht durchgreifen jetzt jagt
ein höchststand die nächsten wir haben
eine explosion der test zahlen sonst
machen wir 100 am tag jetzt mehr als 350
pro tag
mehr infektionen bringen mehr patienten
auf die intensivstationen die meisten
von ihnen sind ungeimpft doch auch beim
personal gibt es im durchbrüche beides
führt zu unterbesetzungen und
überlastung
würde es gibt erschöpfungs wellen wie
bei der epidemie selbst wir haben es
satt das virus greift an immer mehr
stellen in frankreichs arbeitsleben ein
in clermont-ferrand stehen busse still
es fehlt an fahrern ein fünftel von
ihnen ist krank oder kontakt fall
normalerweise können wir ausfälle leicht
ersetzen aber im moment verliert zu
viele aus um das angebot aufrecht zu
erhalten
am nachmittag kamen teile des
regierungskabinetts zusammen um über
neue maßnahmen zu beraten drastische
neue einschränkungen wurden vorab nicht
in aussicht gestellt die regierung kann
da wohl auch wenig machen alles was sie
ankündigen reicht nicht seit zwei jahren
geht das so
ich erwarte nichts von dieser regierung
ich denke sie müssten draußen wieder
eine maske pflicht einführen
wenige monate vor der wahl ist offen
welche belastung präsident marco der
bevölkerung zumutet am abend will die
regierung neue maßnahmen verkünden und
das verzögert sich gerade die
pressekonferenz hat noch nicht begonnen
thomas walde welche neuen maßnahmen
werden da wofür später verkündet werden
einerseits wird erwartet dass die
regierung garantiere regeln sogar
lockern könnte ganz einfach mal zu viele
arbeitnehmer der zeit ausfallen deswegen
und dass die wirtschaft belastet auf der
anderen seite wird damit gerechnet dass
die regierung den druck zum impfen
weiter erhöht ab mitte januar gilt dann
hier nur noch als durchgeimpft in
frankreich wäre auch eine booster
impfung bekommen hat und nur solche
leute können dann noch am öffentlichen
leben teilnehmen die regierung hat immer
gesagt impfen sei der weg zum erfolg nun
hat das land eine hohe impfquoten da
kann die regierung dann auch nicht allzu
harte einschränkungen plötzlich
verkünden und ihren bisherigen kurs
quasi konterkarieren darum hat präsident
makro vor weihnachten nicht hart
durchgegriffen darum ist es
unwahrscheinlich dass er das jetzt tut
wenige monate vor der
präsidentschaftswahl könne es sich nicht
politisch leisten seine landsleute zu
irritieren oder gar zu verprellen mit
einem wochenlangen paten lockdown danke
für diese einschätzung thomas walde aus
paris
auch in deutschland verbreitet sich
omikron immer weiter aktuell sind
bislang laut robert-koch-institut
7225 fälle der virusvariante
festgestellt worden gut 1000 davon kamen
innerhalb eines tages dazu allerdings
sind die korona zahlen insgesamt derzeit
nur bedingt aussagekräftig da wegen der
feiertage weniger sequenziert und
generell weniger getestet und
übermittelt wurde 13 1908 corona neue
infektionen wurden innerhalb von 24
stunden gemeldet ebenso 69 todesfälle
die sieben tage incidents liegt bei
222,7 einer impfung gegen korona in
deutschland sie können eine immunologin
fragen gleich um halb acht und einem
zdf- heute live in unserer app oder auf
den social media kanälen
gegen die korona maßnahmen sind gestern
abend wieder hunderte auf die straße
gegangen in schweinfurt kam es bei einer
unangemeldeten demo zu ausschreitungen
nach angaben der polizei wurden acht
beamte durch fußtritte und schläge
verletzt außerdem ein vierjähriges kind
das mutter versucht mit dem kinderwagen
eine absperrung zu durchbrechen gegen
sie wurde anzeige erstattet
in unserem nachbarland österreich sind
die korona maßnahmen jetzt noch einmal
verschärft worden vor allem aus sorge
vor omikron ab heute gilt unter anderem
eine vorgezogene sperrstunde für
restaurants hotel gastronomie bars auch
zu silvester
besonders der tourismus leidet derzeit
wolf christian ullrich berichtet
szene wird david figur hofft dass die
wiener ein silvester schon mittags den
champagner vorrat plündern denn ab 22
uhr ist jetzt sperrstunde auch ein
silvester wir tragen selbstverständlich
die maßnahme mit aber es war schon ein
großer schock für uns elf
da sozusagen jetzt draußen vorzugeben
die sperrstunde kommt weil österreichs
regierung mit der ausbreitung von
omikron eine neue krise auf den
intensivstationen fürchtet gastgewerbe
und tourismus hatten unter dem jüngsten
lockdown im dezember sehr gelitten die
sperrstunde sorgt deshalb für neue
stoßseufzer bei den party planen wie
hier in seefeld in tirol um 22 uhr haben
die meisten hotels noch nicht einmal das
sieht das menü fertig durch serviert
geschweige denn der gast bürger stimmung
in das neue jahr rein zu kommen auch auf
den skipisten geht es derzeit
entspannter zu als sonst denn wer nach
österreich will muss beachten zweimal
geimpft reicht nicht mehr für die
einreise der booster ist notwendig oder
ein zusätzlicher pcr-test die regeln
machen sind die müssen eingehalten
werden und wenn man sich rechtzeitig
informiert weiß welche regeln
einzuhalten hat dann sich hier auch
keine probleme österreich feiert
silvester in diesem jahr eher zuhause zu
groß die sorge vor einem lokal nummer
fünf im januar
trotz staatlicher hilfen zur bewältigung
der pandemie steht die krankenhäuser in
deutschland wirtschaftlich so schlecht
da wie seit über zwanzig jahren nicht
rund 60 prozent der kliniken rechnen im
ablaufenden jahr mit verlusten so das
krankenhaus barometer des deutschen
krankenhaus instituts das wären dann
doppelt so viele wie im vorjahr
ungeachtet der pandemie unter
lieferengpässe schauen zumindest die
allermeisten wirtschaftsverbände
optimistisch auf das kommende jahr laut
einer umfrage des instituts der
deutschen wirtschaft viele sparten
würden davon ausgehen
20 22 wieder das vorkrisenniveau zu
erreichen aber nicht alles sieht rosig
aus frank buchwald hat sich das genauer
angeschaut
karl heinrich dittmar aus dem
väterlichen betrieb in stemwede bei
osnabrück hat er eines der größeren
deutschen bauunternehmen gemacht und ins
neue jahr blickt er ganz zuversichtlich
trotz corona corinna hat uns ja in den
letzten zwei jahren eigentlich fast
nichts angehabt und wir haben gute
aufträge bekommen in den letzten zwei
jahren wir haben viele großaufträge
dabei so dass wir ganz optimistisch in
das nächste jahr hinein schauen sowie
depenbrock geht es vielen laut iw
verbandsumfrage erwarten 25 von 48
branchen für 2022 bessere geschäfte
nicht nur die bauindustrie 17 verbände
rechnen mit etwa gleicher auslastung 06
sind pessimistisch gleichzeitig melden
die branchen aber auch eine reihe von
problemen die wir alle mittlerweile
kennen lieferprobleme engpässe bei
bestimmten vorprodukten oder rohstoffen
entsprechende preiseffekte und dennoch
ist das bild ganz überwiegend positiv
und zwar in einer doch sehr deutlichen
breite über alle branchen hinweg
das zeigt sich auch bei der
beschäftigung in 21 branchen suchen die
unternehmen neue leute 19 wollen die
beschäftigten halten nur acht bauen ab
ähnliches bild bei den investitionen 24
wirtschaftszweige wollen mehr
investieren
18 branchen halten das niveau nur sechs
setzen den rotstift an auch unternehmer
diepenbrock sucht neue leute wir bauen
nicht zuletzt für den klimaschutz nur
die immer neuen bauvorschriften
die nerven manchmal
polens präsident du da hat das
umstrittene neue rundfunkgesetz vorerst
gestoppt es davor die beteiligung nicht
europäische unternehmen an polnischen
medien zu begrenzen das habe dem ruf des
landes als unternehmensstandort
geschadet so duda landesweit waren
menschen gegen das gesetz auf die straße
gegangen sie kritisierten es gehe darum
einen regierungskritischen us-geführten
sender zum schweigen zu bringen
in wien geht es heute um die zukunft des
atom abkommens mit iran
20.15 wurde der ursprüngliche de
geschlossen er sollte teheran abhalten
atomwaffen zu bauen im gegenzug würden
wirtschaftssanktionen gelockert aber
schon 20 18 stehen die usa unter donald
trump aus seitdem fährt iran sein
atomprogramm schrittweise hoch nach dem
antritt von präsident beiden wollen
beide seiten das abkommen wieder beleben
und so wird heute weiter verhandelt
der iranische außenminister machte heute
in teheran noch einmal die sicht der
iranischen führung klar ergebnis der
heute wieder aufgenommenen atomgespräche
in wien müsste die aufhebung der
sanktionen seien
wir müssen wieder unser öl ohne
beschränkungen verkaufen dürfen das geld
dafür muss auf den iranischen bankkonten
in fremdwährung ankommen wir müssen in
den genuss aller wirtschaftlichen
zugeständnisse kommen die im atom
abkommen festgelegt wurden
dafür wolle man den atominspektoren
wieder zugang zu den nuklearanlagen
gewähren hieß es aus teheran doch ist
das regime tatsächlich bereit
entwicklungen seit dem ende des atom
abkommens wieder zurückzufahren mit
hilfe moderner zentrifugen wurde uran
auf weit über 20 prozent angereichert
experten glauben iran sei heute
technisch in der lage sehr bald eine
bombe zu bauen
die frage ist wie viel waffenfähiges
uran kann iran produzieren und wie
schnell ich denke es sind nur noch
wenige wochen es waren mal viele monate
doch der zeitraum ist geschrumpft auf
nur noch wenige wochen
was iran bislang noch fehle so der
experte sei eine raketentechnik die
zuverlässig atomare sprengköpfe tragen
könne vor wenigen tagen erst
inszenierten irans revolutionsgarden
martialische raketentests und drohten
offen richtung israel
israel sollte aufpassen keine fehler zu
machen beim kleinsten fehler werden wir
ihnen die hände abschneiden
drohgebärden vor den atomgesprächen doch
auch irans führung steht unter druck die
menschen erwarten dass die quellen den
sanktionen endlich ein ende haben
im nordosten von brasilien im
bundesstaat bahia haben lange und
heftige regenfälle rund 40 orte
überflutet
durch die unwetter brachen außerdem zwei
staudämme mit helikoptern und booten
bringen rettungskräfte menschen in
sicherheit die region leidet bereits
wochen lang unter extremem wetter seit
november kamen 18 menschen ums leben
knapp 20.000 wurden obdachlos
dieser bekam hat uns vor allem aber
natürlich die menschen auf la palma
leben ja drei monate in atem gehalten
jetzt aber scheint die gefahr gebannt
der ausbruch von cumbria ist beendet
erklärte die regionalregierung die
bilanz verheerend rot glühend hatte sich
die lava richtung mehr gewälzt und alles
verschlungen was im weg war
lacombe riviera der alte gipfel ist
wieder verstummt kein grollen kein
ascheregen canela ströme mehr die
bizarre landschaft ringsum lockt weiter
touristen auf die insel für 111 ii mit
gruselfaktor
das ist natürlich eine katastrophe aber
sie könnte mittel- und langfristig auch
ihr gutes haben sagt dieser tour ist la
palma könnte davon profitieren dass sie
eine vulkaninsel ist
diesen optimismus teilen nicht alle
bewohner mehr als 2300 haben ihr obdach
verloren der alltag ganzer dörfer
verschwunden unter meter dicken
ascheschicht
für die touristen mag es schön sein was
einmaliges zu sehen man diese
bewohnerinnen für uns bleibt es
schmerzhaft wegen all dem was hier
19 september der vulkan erwacht viele
haben nur wenige minuten um ein paar
habseligkeiten zusammen zu raffen der
ausbruch teilt ihr leben ein davor und
ein danach
auf 900 millionen euro schätzt die
inselregierung die schäden plantagen
gebäude straßen die über jahrhunderte
gewachsene zivilisation ohne chance
gegen die mehr als 1000 grad heiße lava
unbändige pure energie die neue
landkarten zeichnet noch immer vergiften
gase die luft die wissenschaftler
beobachten den vulkan weiter mit argwohn
es gibt weiter erschütterungen die
werden auch erstmal bleiben wir müssen
jetzt an überwachungsnetz aufbauen um
die austretenden gase zu kontrollieren
bis zu 40 grad warm ist die frische
decke aus lavagestein noch instabil wie
die zukunft der insel nach 85 tagen
vulkanausbruch
regen und bodenfrost mit dieser
gefährlichen kombination hat sich das
winterwetter in der nacht von seiner
weniger schönen seite gezeigt betroffen
hat es vor allem den osten deutschlands
wie hier in thüringen waren straßen und
gehwege teils spiegelglatt und auch auf
den autos bildete sich ein dicker
eispanzer eine herausforderung für alle
die zu fuß unterwegs waren aber mehr
noch für alle die auto führen sogar bis
wie hier bei zwickau zahlreiche unfälle
mehr als 100 corona infektion bin einer
woche meldet die englische premier
league das sorgte für einige aufregung
ja und das beeinflusst auch die
fürsorgepflicht vieler trainer genau wie
jürgen klopp beklagte auch thomas tuchel
die große belastung der spieler über den
3 1 erfolg seines fc chelsea bei aston
villa konnte er sich nur bedingt freuen
mit säuerlicher miene weniger weil er
mit den blues bei aston villa durch ein
eigentor in rückstand geriet sondern
weil er weiter gegen die wechsel regel
von nur drei spielern in corona zeiten
protestiert zwar gelingt chelsea durch
einen foulelfmeter von giorgio noch in
der ersten hälfte der ausgleich aber
letzte option nach zwei
verletzungsbedingten auswechslung war
dann rom
karten der noch corona geschwächt
trotzdem zum 2 1 traf
ich kann überhaupt nicht verstehen warum
wir die einzige liga die im winter durch
spielt nur dreimal wechseln dürfen und
lykke friis absieht lukaku wurde noch
umgesäbelt und so sorgte schien mit
seinem zweiten elfmeter tor für den 3
1-auswärtssieg
achtelfinale verpasst florian hempel dem
früheren zweitliga handballer hat die
weihnachtspause anscheinend nicht gut
getan der 31 jährige kölner verliert bei
der darts wm in london sein
drittrundenspiel gegen den australier
eamon smith mit eins zu vier
es ist die anerkennung für den sieger
florian hempel der wm-debütant hat
gekämpft doch der australier raymond
smith ist heute zu stark
beeindruckend seine stoische ruhe fast
bewegungslos nähert er sich der scheibe
technisch exzellent schnell kann sich
der erfahrene australier absetzen führt
3 zu 1 nach sätzen hempels körpersprache
nicht die eines champions selten sind
momente wie diese die
sensation auf der größten darf bühne der
welt bleibt somit aus der 42 jährige
australier smith gewinnt souverän mit 4
1 und steht nun im achtelfinale
ja war volltreffer aber nicht so viele
denken beim wetter ist am ort mit glätte
zu rechnen die einzelheiten gleich von
austin telli das heute-journal können
sie um 21 45 sehen mit claus kleber auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter um die kälte aus
dem osten abzudrängen brauchen wir
einige tiefs und genauso sieht es in den
nächsten tagen aus in mehreren schüben
kommt ihr warmluft und dazu auch viel
wind und so wird die kälte allmählich
abgedrängt in der nacht gibt es nochmal
glatte straßen von der ostsee über die
mitte bis nach südosten hin hier
teilweise glatteis dabei ansonsten kommt
von westen her der regen weiter ins
landesinnere voran ja und die
temperaturen sinken dazu im osten auf
minus fünf grad ganz im westen deutlich
milder bei acht grad und auch im
südwesten deutschlands morgen
tagesverlauf ist eine ganze menge los
der regen setzt sich weiter vorwärts
richtung osten ja und da gibt es auch
noch mal klette ganz im westen
deutschlands bilden sich einzelne
gewitter und dazu gibt's stürmischen
wind temperaturen dazu höchste werte mit
zwei grad an der ostsee und 13 grad im
südwesten deutschlands die kommenden
tage gehen noch milder weiter am
mittwoch ist es noch im osten kalt aber
allmählich wird die kälte abgedrängt 3
bis 14 grad zu viel regen donnerstag
temperaturen bis 16 grad und silvester
ebenfalls und dazu sogar stürmischer
wind schöner abend